s
années, Vincent Boulay
s'apprête, le 20 janvier
d'un des reins de sa conjointe.
VINCENT ULULAY
- Le don que Mélanie fait, là,
c'est... c'est inestimable.
- J'ai de beaux gros reins
enananté. Tout fonctionne...
parfaitement, fait que c'est
pour ça que je peux donner
- Pour éviter de contracterune t
déjà être en isolement depuis
la fin décembre. Il sera en a as
deux mois après l'opération.
Pour ces trois mois d'arrêt de
travail, Mme Dupont n'a droit
qu'à 55 % de son salurururururu,
ce que déplore le couple.
- 55 % de mon salaire,
avec le coût de la
bien, c'est pas...
c'est pas beaucoup, l
- À cela peut s'aererer d'autre.
Dans la province,les travailleut
à deux journées payées
pour faire un don d'organeplplpc
peut aussi offrir aux donneurs
une compensation allant jusqu'à
près de 6000 $, mais en raison ,
Mme Dupont dit n'avoir droit
qu'à 60 $ supplémentaires
par semaine.
- Mais, moi, donner un rein,
là, je veux dire,
il m'en reste un, là!
- Pa
pour sa santé.
- J'ai pas besoin de faire ça
pour ma santé, là.a a a a a a at
d'argent au gouvernement
parce que les traitements
de dialyse que je fais coûtent
environ tatatatatatatatatatatate
à peu près... 25 000 $.
- En Nouvelle-Zélande,
depuis 2017, les personnes qui
sont dédommagées à 100 % pour
leur perte de salaire engendrée
par l'opération. Depuis,
les dons vivants ont triplé;
la moitié des greffes.
- On est en retard au Québec,
on est en retard au Canada.
peut aussi compter sur plus
$ $ $ $ $ qu'ils ont réussi
à récolter grâce à un site
de dons en ligne.s,s,s,s,s,s,s,,
là, t'sais, à chaque fois qu'ont
surpris, c'est incroyable.
- Un comité d'experta égalements
au gouvernement du Québec
des recommandations suggérant
des augmentations substantielles
offertes aux donneurs.
Ici Louis-Philippe Arsenault,
Radio-Canada, Québe